check check one two audio check one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
good
yes
okay
um
hey
thank you
good morning guys
uh
hello everybody
good morning
i just uh signed a request to congress
for critical security economic and
humanitarian assistance
uh to help ukraine continue to counter
putin's aggression
and a very pivotal moment
we need this bill to support ukraine in
this fight for freedom and our nato
allies our eu partners they're going to
pay their fair share of the cost as well
but we have to do this we have to do our
part as well leading the alliance now
the cost of this fight
is not cheap
but caving to aggression is going to be
more costly if we allow it to happen
we either back ukrainian people as they
defend their country or
we stand by as the russians continue
their atrocities and aggression in
ukraine
every day
every day the ukrainians pay for the
price with the price they pay for their
lives for this fight
so we need to contribute arms funding
ammunition and the economic support to
make their courage and sacrifice have
purpose so they can continue this fight
and do what they're doing
it's critical this funding gets approved
and approved as quickly as possible
you know long before russia lost to
launch his brutal invasion
i i made clear how the united states
would respond
predicted they would invade and uh they
surely did
we said we not send u.s troops to fight
russian troops in ukraine but we would
provide
robust military assistance and try to
unify the western world against russia's
aggression
i said i would impose powerful sanctions
on russia and that we destroy and
develop we destroy
this myth that somehow they continue to
move without the rest of the world
acting
that we deploy additional forces to
defend nato territories particularly in
the east along the russian and belarus
borders
that's exactly that's exactly what we
said we would do and we did but despite
the disturbing rhetoric coming out of
the kremlin the facts are plain for
everybody to see
we're not attacking russia we're helping
ukraine defend itself against russian
aggression
and just as putin chose to launch this
brutal invasion
he could make the choice to end this
brutal invasion
russia is the aggressor no if ends or
buts about it russia is the aggressor
and the world must and will hold russian
accountable
russia continues assault on is yielding
immense human cost
we've seen
we've seen them leave behind horrifying
evidence of their atrocities and war
crimes
and the areas they tried to control
and as long as the assaults and
atrocities continue we're going to
continue to supply military assistance i
might know parenthetically
you know there's a dinner this weekend
to celebrate the press
think of what the american press has
done
the courage is taken
to stay
in these war zones the courage has taken
the report every single day
i've always had respect for the press
but i can't tell you how much respect i
have watching watching them in these
zones where they're under fire
risking their own lives to make sure the
world hears the truth
imagine if we weren't getting that
information
it'd be a different world it'd be a
different circumstance
in the past two months russia launched
his brutal attack has moved weapons and
equipment to ukraine that we've moved
we've moved weapons and equipment and to
ukraine in record speed
thanks to the aid we provided russian
forces have been forced to retreat from
key doesn't mean they're not going to
try to come back but they've retreated
thus far
we've sent thousands of anti-armor
anti-missiles helicopters drones grenade
launchers machine guns rifles radar
systems
more than 50 million rounds of
ammunition
the united states alone has provided 10
anti-armor systems for every russian
tank that is in ukraine ten to one
providing ukraine significant timely
intelligence to help them defend
themselves against the russian onslaught
and we're facilitating a significant
flow of weapons and systems of ukraine
from our allies and partners around the
world
including tanks artillery and other
weapons
that support is moving with
unprecedented speed
much much of the new equipment we've
announced
in the past two month two weeks has
already gotten to ukraine where it can
be put to direct use on the battlefield
however
we've almost exhausted what we call the
fancy phrase the drawdown authority that
congress authorized ukraine for
authorized ukraine in a bipartisan
spending bill last month
basically we're out of money
and so that's why today in order to
sustain ukraine as a as it continues to
fight i'm sending congress a
supplemental budget request
it's going to keep weapons and
ammunition flowing without interruption
to the brave ukrainian fighters and
continue delivering economic and
humanitarian assistance to the ukrainian
people
this so-called supplemental funding
addresses the needs of the ukrainian
military during the critical weeks and
months ahead
and it begins and begins to transition
to longer term security systems that's
going to help ukraine deter and continue
to defend against russian aggression
this assistance would provide even more
artillery
armored vehicles anti-armored systems
anti-air capabilities
that have been used so effectively thus
far in the battlefield by the ukrainian
warriors
you know it's going to deliver
much-needed humanitarian assistance as
well as food water medicine shelter and
other aid to ukrainians displaced by
russia's war
and provide aid for those seeking refuge
in other countries from ukraine
it's also going to help schools and
hospitals open
it's going to allow pensions and social
support to be paid to the ukrainian
people so they have something something
in their pocket
it's also going to provide critical
resources to address food shortages
around the globe
ukraine
ukraine was one of the world's largest
agricultural producers
it typically grows 10 of all the wheat
that's shipped around the world
putin
has asserted sanctions are blocking food
from ukraine and russia getting on the
market the sanctions we've imposed on
russia simply not true
putin's war not sanctions
are impacting the harvest of food and
disrupting the movement
of that food by land and see to nations
around the globe that need it
this funding is going to help ease
rising food prices at home as well and
abroad caused by russia's war in ukraine
it's going to help support american
farmers produce more crops like wheat
and oil seed which is good for rural
america good for the american consumer
and good for the world
and this supplemental request will use
the defense production act to expand
domestic production
and reserve and the reserve of critical
materials
materials like nickel and lithium that
have been disrupted by putin's war in
ukraine and that are necessary to make
everything from defense systems to
automobiles
and i hope congress i hope congress will
move on this funding quickly i believe
they will
i want to thank congress democrats and
republicans for the support of people of
ukraine
and next week i will be in alabama
to visit lockheed martin plant that
manufactures the javelin anti-tank
missile we've been sending to ukraine
and to thank the american workers
thank them for producing the weapons
that helped stop russia's advances in
ukrainian cities like key
their hard work has played a critical
role in ensuring putin's strategic
failure in ukraine and they should know
that we know it
in addition to this supplemental funding
i'm also sending to congress a
comprehensive package
of uh that will enhance our underlying
effort to accommodate the russian
oligarchs and make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocracy
yeah
kleptocracy and clip the guys who are
the kleptocracies
but these are bad guys
this legislative package strengthens our
law enforcement capabilities
to seize property linked
to russia's kleptocracy
it's going to create new expedited
procedures
for forfeiture and seizure of these
these properties and it's going to
ensure that when the oligarchs assets
are sold off
funds can be used directly to remedy the
harm russia caused in their help and
helped build ukraine
additionally yesterday
russia threatened two of our allies with
a cutoff of energy supplies
while america has ended all russian
fossil fuel imports because we're able
to use our vast support supply of power
in our country
some european countries have faced more
challenges in reducing the reliance on
russian fuel
russia has long claimed to be quote the
reliable source of energy for the world
no matter what the differences are their
customers are always going to be
in good shape
but these actions prove that energy is
not just a commodity that russia sells
to help meet other countries needs but a
weapon
we use to deploy against those who stand
against her aggression
let me be clear
we will not let russia intimidate or
blackmail their way out of these
sanctions
we will not allow them to use their oil
and gas to avoid consequences for the
aggression
we're working with other nations like
korea japan qatar and others to support
our effort to help european allies
threatened by russia with gas blackmail
and their energy needs in other ways
aggression
will not win threats will not win this
is just another reminder
of the imperative for europe and the
world to move more and more of our power
needs to clean energy
in the united states we're doing that
right now last year we developed more
solar wind and battery storage than any
year in our history
enough to power 56 million american
homes
earlier this month we acted to bolster
the or reliant the reliance on our
nuclear energy facilities which
generates more than half of our
carbon-free power
and we're just getting started
i look at this as a serious problem but
also an enormous opportunity an
opportunity
bottom line
all these actions we've been taking
are about the truth this truth investing
in ukraine's freedom and security is a
small price to pay to punish russia and
aggression to lessen the risk for future
conflicts
you know throughout our history
we've learned that when dictators do not
pay the price for their aggression
they cause more chaos and engage in more
aggression
they keep moving and the cost
the threats to america and the world
keep rising we can't let this happen
our unity at home
our unity with our allies and partners
and our unity with the ukrainian people
is sending an unmistakable message to
putin
you will never succeed in dominating
ukraine
finally
we're going to continue to deliver
critical support to ukraine
we must also not let our guard down in
our fight against covet 19 at home and
abroad
that's why i'm again urging congress to
act on my request
for 22.5 billion dollars in emergency
resources so the american people can
continue to protect themselves from kobe
19.
the reason we were so successful in the
past
is because i was able to work with drug
manufacturers to order significant
quantities of material we needed ahead
of time to get in the front of the line
without additional funding we can't
pre-order the amount of vaccines we need
and we risk losing our spot in line for
vaccines that target multiple variants
we're running out of supply for
therapeutics like anti-viral pills that
we desperately need
without additional funding we're unable
to purchase a life-saving treatment for
the american people
we've donated more vaccines and
treatments to the world than all other
nations in the world combined
if the us won't do it no one else is
really going to step up and do it
without additional funding the united
states won't be able to help stop to
spread around the world and close off
ongoing support
sources
of the supply chain disruptions
look
let's get both of these critical tasks
done
no delays no excuses just action now
now
thank you all thank you
[Music]
your messages to ukrainian refugees on
the southwest border and those that are
trying to flee ukraine from the violence
we have
made a direct means by which they can
get from europe from ukraine directly to
the united states without going to the
southern border in the meantime in the
southern border we're trying to work
through
and make sure that it's an orderly
process they're able to get in but just
so you know
we have said there's no need to go to
the southern border fly directly to the
united states we set up a mechanism
whereby they can come directly with the
visa
russian comments
in the media and on some of their
officials painting this conflict as
actually already a conflict between nato
the us
and russia that means very alarmist
terms talking nuclear weapons
saying it's a life or death struggle etc
and just separate what commences that
lavrov himself says it's already a proxy
war not a direct war but a prophecy war
so are either those two things true and
do they worry those things
they're not true they do concern me
because it shows the desperation
that russia is feeling about their
abject failure in being able to do what
they set out to do in the first instance
and so
it uh
i think it's more of a reflection not on
the truth but of their failure
and so instead of saying that the
uh the ukrainians equipped with
some capability to resist russian
forces
are doing this they've got to say tell
their people the united states and all
of nato is engaged in taking out russian
troops and tanks etc so it's number one
is an excuse for their failure
but number two it's also if they really
mean it it's it's a it's
no no one should be
making idle comments about the use of
nuclear weapons or the possibility to
use that it's irresponsible
mr president back on the border title 42
a number of your democratic friends are
pressuring the white house to
maintain that policy can you give us a
straight answer whether you're going
to
heed that request or you're going to get
rid of it
i'll give you a straight answer we had
proposed to
eliminate that policy
uh by the end of may the court has said
we can't so far
and what the court says we're going to
do the court could come along and say we
cannot do that and that's it
russia clearly disagrees they say that
war means war so how concerned are you
that they may start to act accordingly
even if you disagree
we are prepared for whatever they
what options do you have to ensure
poland and bulgaria have sufficient
supplies of gas
first of all as you know
poland has indicated they have
significant reserves of gas that they
have planned for
as does not as much but as does bulgaria
and we have worked with our allies from
japan on to say that we may
divert our sale of the natural gas that
we're sending to those countries and
divert it directly to uh to
poland and
bulgaria so i
you know it's as much i can tell you
right now sir how concerning you about a
recession given the gdp reports today
show the contraction of one point four
percent of the
well i i i'm not concerned about a
recession and i mean you're always
concerned about uh
recession but the gdp
you know fell to 1.4 percent but here's
the deal
we also had last quarter consumer
spending and business investment
residential investment increased at
significant rates both for leisure as
well as hard products
number one number two
they we are unemployment's the lowest
rate since 1970.
a record 4.5 million businesses were
created last year
we're in a situation where
the uh you know we have a very different
view than
senator scott the republicans
want to raise taxes on the middle class
families and want to include half the
small business owners and that
we so
i think we're
what you're seeing is enormous growth
in the country
that was affected by
everything from covet and the covert
blockages that we occurred along the way
now you always have to be uh take a look
and no one is predicting every session
now they're predicting that some are
predicting there may be a recession in
2023.
um i'm concerned about it but i know one
thing
that uh you know if our republican
friends are really interested in doing
something about dealing with
economic growth and they should help us
continue to lower the deficit which
we've done last year with 350 billion
dollars
they should be willing to work with us
to have a tax code that is actually one
that
um
works and everybody pays their fair
share
and they should be uh in a position
where uh
you shouldn't be raising taxes on
middle-class folks you should be raising
taxes on people who everyone
acknowledges that the vast majority
republicans aren't paying their fair
share i've said it 100 times
you have
you know 50 major corporations of the
fortune 500 companies made 40 billion
dollars last year didn't pay a single
penny
no one under our proposal anything under
400 000 a year will see a penny in their
taxes go up not one penny
do you think copenhagen and ukraine
should be tied together in legislation
well i don't care how they talk how they
do it i'm sending them both up i mean
they can do it separately or together
but we need them both mr president uh
shorty leader schumer said yesterday
that you're getting closer to using
executive authority to cancel up to
fifty thousand dollars in a student loan
debt can you confirm that what exactly
are you looking to plan to do here in
the coming you mean my spokesman said
that
majority leadership
um look uh
number one uh one first thing we did was
reform the system that was in place that
didn't work for anybody
that allowed people to write off debt if
they engaged in public service
we have almost a million 785 don't hold
me the exact number i'll get the number
700 some thousand have had debt forgiven
their whole debt forgiven because of
their work working in these various
teachers or other means by which they
qualify and we continue to make that
easier secondly i am considering
dealing with some debt reduction i am
not considering 50 000 debt reduction
but i'm in the process of taking a hard
look at whether or not
there are gonna there will be additional
debt forgiveness and uh i'll have an
answer on that in the next couple weeks
thank you
thank you guys
you